Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 1st,
2012,
um,
first day of October.
I got a question for you.
When is the fucking summer going to end?
You know,
I don't want to be these guys,
one of these guys who the first time is a fucking heat wave starts going.
See there's global warming.
I think I proved my point.
You know,
like when it snows in February and the people who don't believe in global
warming go like,
well gee,
what happened to global warming?
It's fucking snowing out yet.
Spouse too.
It's supposed to.
It's fucking January.
Get Dumb cunt.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
I'm going out to La and we're going to have another five day fucking heat wave
like 99 fucking degrees every God damn day.
And uh,
I don't have air conditioning in my house.
You gonna Laugh at me now.
You know,
I kind of live in an area where we get a nice breeze and I was told that by the
people who I bought the house off of that.
Yeah,
that's really not a problem.
Can you believe that?
They were deceitful.
You know what sucks about having a fucking houses every time you think you got
everything fixed,
you know
it's just something else comes along.
I thought I was finally caught up.
I widen the doors in the garage.
I got the God damn hot water fucking thing outside.
I went tankless,
I got that done.
I fixed the fucking cabinets.
You know I got screens on the windows.
Okay,
the fuck else did I do.
I got the stupid fucking thing fixed it.
You know the hot air goes out of on the laundromat on,
on the,
on the dryer,
all these little cunty knickknack fucking things and I was thinking all I gotta
do now is have somebody fucking get my chimney up to code
and then clean out some other God damn thing.
And I was done now and I got to put a new roof on it too.
So I'm thinking,
all right,
the roof,
that's the most expensive thing.
I'll get that thing done.
Right.
What's the point of fixing and everything else if it's just going to get wet,
right.
Figured that was my next move.
Then out of fucking nowhere,
I got Nia Colomy up QE,
choose kit,
one of those standalone units.
Qhs just get a C in one room.
Unbelievable.
I thought it was in the clear,
it's fucking October.
Okay,
well,
Coos,
kitten home.
I live in a Goddamn desert.
At some point I'm going to have to get air conditioning,
but now most of feeling like a pussy because everybody else,
whoever owned by fucking house,
they somehow dealt with it.
Maybe sat on the front steps,
drinking a mint,
mint,
Julep socializing with the neighbors,
talking about Pearl Harbor or whatever the they did.
Okay,
well they had tougher breed back then,
or is this global warming thing actually,
uh,
something that's true.
Yeah.
Well actually
it is getting warmer.
You know,
it's just the debate is,
I'm so in over my head,
just,
just enter,
entertain me,
just go with me on this.
The big debate is whether or not human beings have an effect on it.
I just,
you know,
you know what's funny is I can't even take myself seriously because every time I
tried to talk about a heavy subject,
my brain is just screaming at me.
You don't read or you haven't read up on any of this.
You've only overheard conversations,
so why don't you shut the fuck up.
Um,
anyways,
this is a podcast for this week.
Everybody,
it's football Sunday.
I'm here in Jacksonville,
Florida.
It's five minutes to one,
five minutes before Bup,
Bup,
bup,
do to,
to,
to all the games are going to start already predicted on my Twitter account that
the Patriots were going to win 63 to five today against the buffalo bills.
And I stand by that.
That's actually what I'm hoping it's going to happen.
And it's somebody,
are you predicting you're going to get his safety?
No.
What's going to happen is we're going to be up 63 to three are punters gonna
feel bad for you.
So you just going to kind of run out of the back of the end zone,
you know,
just to give you another two fucking points,
you know what's the worst thing about going to a buffalo bills game,
aside from the lingering sadness of losing four super bowls in a row is
listening to that dumb chant that let's go buffalo.
I hate fucking,
first of all,
it rhymes,
you know?
Yay.
Let's go buffalo.
The AFC.
He says some of the worst fucking chance in just in all of professional sports.
J E t s jazz,
jazz charts,
her,
hey,
it's like,
what fucking year is it?
Okay,
let's go buffalo.
Those are some angry mother fuckers out there.
I'll tell you,
that may versus a few years ago we went to that fucking bills jets game.
Somebody pushed me in the back while I was taking a piss because they had a
patriots hat on.
You know,
fucking losers out there,
man.
Fucking losers.
You know,
I love how they act.
Like they didn't have video cameras out there.
You know,
fucking mob levy could easily just film the other team.
And one.
One of those super bowls.
You didn't want to do it.
Yeah,
it didn't want to do it.
You made me feel you.
Why didn't want to do it?
Why don't they just,
you know,
listen buffalo,
if he could learn anything from some of your,
your compadres here in the AFC,
if you can't beat them,
cheat for the love of God.
How long are you going to have that mom and pop store?
We're making our own jam.
Putting in an extra fucking pickle jars.
Vibe.
Yeah.
First of all,
you know what your problem is buffalo.
You don't even deserve a professional fucking franchise.
Do you understand that?
Do you want understand how if you didn't have the bills and the sabers that the
amount of people wouldn't even know like you,
you'd be like Elmira.
You'd be one of those fucking towns.
Nobody even knew about you guys fucking peeked back when people took road.
Like when going to Niagara Falls was was was like a fucking,
you know,
place where you went on your honeymoon.
Fuzzy,
irregular.
Joe couldn't afford to fly.
All right?
That's why you've never won anything because God forgets that you exist.
Why am I being so mean to them?
I actually think I'm going to be performing there next year.
I have no idea.
You know actually the reality is with this whole fucking patriots' defense,
I,
you know,
and we've got a rookie fucking trying to protect Tom Brady's blind side.
I got,
I have no idea.
And it's a divisional rivalry.
We usually go one and one against the bills.
You know the bills usually when one and then shred and Reagan called me up like
gauge gt gay would you dig about dead right.
And they get all fucking excited.
They start talking super bowl and then the next time we play and we raped them.
You know,
we put that red ball thing in their mouth,
bend them over and shoved the football right up to harass.
You know,
it's common,
you know it is
okay.
Who has more false hope?
A bills fan or a jets fan?
I think it's a jets fan just because they look like that guy.
The Mush in a Bronx tale.
Like your average fucking jets fan.
That's what he,
that's what he looks like.
You know?
And I'm not saying that the average patriots fan doesn't look like a fucking
alcoholic.
Lucky charms.
Fucking dude.
I'm not even saying that.
I would never try to say that.
We don't look like a bunch of fucking drunk potatoes.
All right.
I'm not saying that we don't.
All right,
but you guys just have that.
Let's go like off track betting.
That's what you're,
that's what the upper deck of a jets game looks like.
I Dunno if it's those awful fucking green jerseys.
You know,
if you're going to get the jets jersey,
you gotta get,
you gotta get the white one man.
What the gray numbers when it's that fucking just pea soup.
Forest Green.
That's just one of the worst fucking jerseys ever.
But you know what?
At the end of the day,
it's still a great game.
See,
I would positive there at the end of the day,
it's still a great game.
I actually some fight with some fucking Jack off on Twitter,
right?
Yeah.
Cause I announced,
I tweeted that I was going to be going to the Jacksonville Jaguars.
Cincinnati Bengals game,
can you fucking believe that I'm hanging around an extra day in Jacksonville to
watch that contest?
Okay.
Is that not going to beat one of the most lowest rated football games of the
year?
MMM.
Do I have the hiccups?
Jesus Christ.
MMM.
But anyways,
I got into this Twitter argument with some guy or I'm guessing he's from fucking
Great Britain or Ireland or some shit and the in,
once again,
like those guys are so on their own dicks.
If they,
if they fucking watch rugby,
you know what I mean?
Like the,
the,
the amount of time.
Either there's soccer fans over there and then they always come up with,
they think that's the most clever Seinfeld thing ever.
They're always like,
why do they call it football one are using,
you know,
like
the excitement in their emails or their,
their tweets when they send that to me as if they're the first person who ever
came up with that little clever analogy.
Okay.
You know,
first of all,
okay,
football came out of soccer.
Okay.
We were kicking the ball around,
you know,
playing your dumb little fucking game.
That was brought over.
Okay,
but because we're fucking Americans
and we know we know how to fucking make shit exciting,
we know how to ramp shit up.
We're not stuck in the past like you guys with your dumb fucking castles talking
about over a hundred the year.
He's told fucking Lilliputian.
Who gives a fuck,
Huh?
Yeah.
Dumb ass fucking history of the Goddamn serfs and the landowners and the feudal
system and you're fucking Catholics Protestants.
Nobody gives a fuck.
Okay.
Yeah.
Half Horse,
half fucking man walking around with that fucking flute or whatever the hell it
did.
You bunch of Goddamn perverts a shirtless man coming out of a horse with the
fuck is wrong with you.
You're going to sit here and criticize our games sitting.
Let's say that that that NFL,
that rugby is a tougher game than NFL football.
You know what rugby looks like to me?
Rugby looks like NFL football.
If the fans ran on the field and started playing,
not saying they're not tough fans.
Not saying they're not fans who have gold member gold gym memberships.
I'm not even trying to say that.
I wouldn't insult you by trying to say that.
I'm just saying it just looks like like really fast.
People from the stance went out there during halftime.
Kind of like when you watch an Nhl game and they let those,
those fucking kids come out and play a little mini one on one,
right?
We got fucking swamp Scott for his model had today.
They showed see scores.
All right.
I'm not saying rugby isn't a tough game.
I'm not saying it's not a beautiful game and I'm not saying it's not an all.
I fucking love it.
I go over there,
I watch it.
If I had time,
I would go to a game.
I think it's great,
but for you fucking Ian,
Mick fucking pasty Fox to sit here and try and act as though they're a bunch of
fucking white guys running around in shorts.
If fucking Polo shirts tackling each other,
you know,
is the equivalent to fucking someone on of of Ray Lewis's ability.
You're,
you're out of your mind.
You're out of your fucking mind.
I can tell you right now,
you can judge the level of your sport by the amount of white guys that are
playing it at a professional level.
You can certainly judge the speed of it.
Okay?
Rugby looks like you're watching the NBA in the 1960s you know,
and checked steals it.
You know,
and one of the big things that rugby people always say is they say NFL players
are pussies.
Okay?
NFL players of pussies.
Just step back and just wrap your head around that because they wear pads,
you know,
and I get why they say that because to look at it,
you're like,
oh,
they have all these pads on.
It doesn't hurt them because they have all this padding on.
You know what it is?
You guys never played the fucking game.
Okay?
I played rugby,
was called kill the man with the ball.
I've played it.
Yes,
I got took knees and I took shots.
But you know what I didn't do?
I never really led with my head.
And you know why?
Because they didn't have a fucking helmet on.
Nobody really lead.
You lead with your shoulder and you tackled with the shoulder just like they do
in rugby.
I'm not saying,
hey that heads don't collide.
I'm not saying there aren't fucking collisions and broken bones.
Okay.
I'm just saying,
first of all,
the helmet is,
is what you're looking at it as an unbelievable design floor.
What it really is is it's just a battering ram.
It protects the skull.
It does not protect the brain.
Okay.
Do you guys have like when rugby players are done playing rugby,
is their heads so fucked up that they shoot themselves in the chest so their
brain can be donated to science to figure out what the fuck happened to him?
Do you have that happen?
Have you ever had somebody go,
you know what,
uh,
um,
I want to play this week so cut the end of my finger off so I can,
I can go out and actually play this week.
You know,
do you have people doing shit like that?
You
know,
as they run their fucking,
they're fucking ten second forties over there.
Look,
I'm not saying it's a tough game.
I'm not saying this is not a fucking,
you know,
I'm not saying those guys aren't faster than me,
but if you put Ray Lewis on a fucking rugby field,
you would be picking up limbs.
Limbs would be littered all over the field.
All right,
so that's it.
The debate is over and you can fucking do anything you want to do.
Send me a tweet,
send me your fucking emails and all that type of shit.
All right,
you guys started it.
I never said rugby was a pussy game.
I still haven't.
You guys constantly send me fucking emails telling me that NFL football players
are pussies.
Let me tell you something right now.
The average NFL player is big enough to grab your entire family by the throat
and choke,
slam you on your fucking knights of the round table.
Fucking table.
All right,
so there you go.
There's your fodder for this week.
You fucking cunts.
Um,
oh.
Meanwhile,
Hey,
by the way,
my special is available for download this week.
It's available,
available for download for $5 off of my website.
I would appreciate it if you guys would go on and,
uh,
and download the son of a bitch cause it costs me a lot of money and I'd like to
try to make my money back.
Um,
and if he could tell me your favorite,
please don't post it on Youtube.
I'm not having an encrypted and all that shit cause that's not fair to people
who aren't going to do something bad with it.
Just do me a favor.
Okay.
Just give me six months.
Just give me a six months window to fucking sell this thing so I can make my
money back.
You know,
so I can go and make another one so I don't have to shoot my next special on a
fucking iPhone.
Um,
if you could do that for me,
I would greatly appreciate it.
So,
hey,
here's,
here's your time to act now.
It Bill bird.com Monday morning,
you go on,
you download the fucking special for $5.
That is the deal.
$5 five bucks.
Can you,
can you look into your heart?
Um,
so anyways,
all let's,
let's,
let's get,
let's get one of these fucking commercials out of the Goddamn way before,
before I get going here.
You know,
these people complain.
Cry.
She didn't read my commercial until 50 minutes.
I did a podcast,
a,
yeah.
Word.
Who the hell's even listening anymore?
Why did I make my password in Spanish?
Huh?
Why would I do that?
Come on.
Open Up.
No,
as a problem.
Come on.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Went,
I want to shot some guns when I was out here.
Do you know silencers are fucking legal in Florida.
They actually had like semiautomatic rifles with silences on the fucking wall.
I'm going to say I got some pictures,
hopefully posted on the podcast page of that.
Um,
it's fucking hilarious.
I mean,
there was Versie and they actually,
uh,
you know,
it's always scary when you were going to go to the gun range and you just send
them with a bunch of strangers with loaded fucking guns.
MMM.
Do you know,
and there's always like that one fucking novice in there that just,
you know,
or not even,
they're just so comfortable.
If they start doing dumb shit,
like loading the gun on the other side and then turning around and walking with
the fucking thing up.
Just like load it at the,
at the,
I don't know what the terminology is.
I'm one of those green horns.
I probably shouldn't even be in there,
but I fucking,
I just had that thing pointed down fucking range.
The whole God damn time.
I load it right where I'm going to shoot it and when it's done,
I fucking take the clip out.
I fucking,
that's it.
Safety on and I just have it pointed down range.
At no point do I ever take that fucking thing.
Even pointing it at the floor,
turn around and walk.
Okay.
Back to the whatever,
the fucking back areas and then load it.
They,
I hate when people do that shit.
Um,
anyway,
so I'm actually at the gun range and this fucking guy cause walkabout by,
he goes,
hey,
you built bar?
And I was like,
yeah.
He goes,
I'm going to see you tonight at the comedy zone.
I go,
that's cool.
Right.
Any fucking opens up.
He has like,
it looks like a look up mechanics tool chest.
Yeah,
like a chrome plated fucking desert eagle in there.
That's a 50 caliber fucking psycho gun.
And he had all this shit with like a silencer and I go,
Holy Shit Dude.
I go the,
I go,
you got a silencer?
And the guy goes,
yeah,
and you're going to shoot it.
So I'm all excited.
And then I see Versie Versie turns into like a fucking six year old standing
there.
He's got this look on his face.
You know,
like when the teacher goes,
who wants to play with the new toy we bought and pick somebody else.
That was the look versus he had on his face.
Like,
how come you picked him?
Am I,
am I going to get to play with it?
So I actually walked always,
Hey,
is it okay if my buddy shoots it to?
And he said,
yeah.
So I tell versus yesterday he's going to let you shoot it too when he fucking so
fucking face lights up.
Right.
Um,
okay.
It was fucking incredible,
man.
It's fucking incredible.
You can't,
you can't have a silencer or what do they call a suppressor?
Whatever the fuck they call it.
You can't have in New York if you have one in New York,
do you get caught with one of those in New York?
I think that's automatically like fucking 30 years.
They just look at it like you have that because you're planning on murdering
somebody and you don't want anybody to hear,
you know,
silence or really is sort of the bitchy way of killing somebody.
Right.
That's like the passive aggressive,
the passive aggressive route.
You know
p p p
take that.
He voice everybody.
Hey,
you trying to start your own business and you want to sound more professional.
Would you like to,
to sound like you have a whole staff of people working for you that you have
this amazing,
amazing office.
Wouldn't it be great?
Would it be great if you could somehow use your cell phone as your personal
phone and your business phone and have two different numbers when that be great
to have virtual numbers?
Did I say it right?
Yeah.
Virtual numbers or is it viral virtual virtual phone numbers?
You can have as many phone numbers.
Basically,
he could have upwards of,
I don't know how many numbers all rings on your cell phone.
Okay.
They have voice over actors.
You know,
it's basically your mobile phone at work.
He voices perfect for a business person on the move like myself.
Uh,
features of he voice offers includes call forwarding,
toll free 800 numbers.
Auto attended,
advanced voicemail,
voicemail detects voicemail to email.
Um,
you know what's cool about this?
They actually have trained like a voiceover actors.
You know,
you can get whatever accent you want,
like some cool fucking English accent or a French accent,
some sexy lady,
whatever you want.
I mean,
that alone will get people wanting to come to your office.
That doesn't exist,
right?
It's just,
it's just a great way to get the business going.
Or if you already have a business,
um,
click on the voice banner on billboard.com podcast page or go to www dot
[inaudible] dot com slash bill burr to get your exclusive six month free trial.
You can try this thing out for six months.
He voiced your mobile phone at work.
There you go.
That's gotta be the coolest way to start your damn business or start a second
family.
You know,
you live in an entirely different life with that,
couldn't you?
Um,
all right,
what else we got here?
stamps.com everybody,
uh,
when you're running a small business,
your hours aren't the traditional nine to five.
You work around the clock.
So the limited hours of the post office can be frustrating.
That's why you need stamps.com.
Get postage on demand right from your desk whenever you need it.
24,
seven,
uh,
with stamps.com you can buy and print official us postage using your own
computer and your printer.
You know what's great about that too is,
I don't know about you guys,
but like,
uh,
I'm on the road a lot and when I come off the road I have like a week and a half
a male.
I have to sift through it and uh,
I love doing it at night.
Nobody's calling me,
nobody's bugging me.
I get it done.
And the next morning,
it's all stamped,
ready to go in the damn mailbox.
And I feel like I got to jump on the day.
All right,
so stamps.com you can get everything from stamps to shipping labels the instant
you need it than just hand your mail to the mailman.
Here you go.
Uh,
you don't need an expensive postage meeting.
Meet her any more.
Plus you'll never have to go to the post office again.
Okay,
and who's kitten who,
who wants to see those grumpy people ever again?
Anyways,
um,
endorsement.
Why do I always read the wrong thing?
Um,
you can get practically everything on demand these days.
Uh,
like my podcast.
So why wouldn't you do the same with postage using stamps.com?
It's what I use to send out my march for shows.
It's so convenient and easy.
Oh,
I guess I was supposed to put that in my own words.
Hey,
I send my frigging DVDs out with it.
It's awesome.
What more do you want from me?
I get to weigh among the scale right now.
Use My last name,
bur bur for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer includes a digital scale and up to $55 free
postage.
Um,
don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstamps.com bur bur
our go.
No,
I can't say that in the advertising.
All right,
go use it now.
back to the podcast.
So anyways,
we went and uh,
we went shooting
and I got to tell you something.
It's,
it's oddly relaxing.
You know what it is after you get over the fact that you're firing a gun,
you then want to get good at it and you want to hit the target.
And it's almost like you're shooting hoops except you're,
you're shooting at a silhouette of a person.
Does that make sense?
Um,
I actually like revolvers
classic me,
right?
Isn't that just typical?
Make the old fucking curmudgeon doesn't like the new shit.
I'm not into the glocks.
The semiautomatics.
I guess it's nice that you have more bullets,
but I like the fucking wider vibe of just having a Goddamn revolver.
You get a nice big one like that 38,
that first he was shooting the heavier the gun less kick.
It's,
it's phenomenal.
There was this chick next to us shooting a frigging cannon that she was afraid
of.
I hate that shit.
I want to go in there and I wanna I wanna.
I want to go to a shooting range where it's a bunch of fucking navy seals and
everybody is comfortable.
This girl was just like,
oh man.
It was a beautiful gun though.
Is this,
is it crazy to say that they really are fucking beautiful?
Yeah.
I feel like fucking Tom Cruise and taps.
It's fucking beautiful,
man.
I'm serious.
The God damn fucking that beautiful.
Is this freaking everybody out overseas and other,
uh,
American gun nut,
you know,
out of fucking,
why don't you guys have guns over there?
You know,
you cops in England,
the cops in England don't have guns.
Is that right?
Or do they have them now because of all the terrorists?
What do they have?
They have a whistle and that really tall hat.
It's got to slow them down when they're chasing people.
Just,
they'll fucking lack of aerodynamics,
wouldn't it?
Anybody?
All right,
here's something you need to know.
All fucking belly fat face is working out again and uh,
actually went,
this isn't an advertisement.
I went out and bought a pegboard and I'm hanging them up in the garage.
Do I stutter?
And,
um,
okay.
Um,
I'm totally,
I'm fucking all about that now.
The grip strength,
I don't think I'll ever go to the gym again and fucking sit there and bench
press and all that.
You don't need to do it.
You just need to do pushups.
All I need to do is move your own fucking body.
You don't need to go down there.
I mean,
unless you try it out for the NFL,
you know,
or you're playing rugby.
Look at that.
I gave rugby respect,
you know,
this is what it goes to the lingerie league,
rugby and then NFL football bottom to top,
you know.
Um,
all right,
let's get to some questions this week.
Everybody.
All right.
Uh,
college broads,
college broads.
Oh,
by the way,
you know something.
You know the great thing about fucking,
you know this rope climbing shit that I'm doing,
doing pull ups and now I've got this pegboard thing.
I actually,
I'm on the eighth floor of this hotel and I'm telling you right now,
I could climb down the fucking side.
It's a bunch of balconies and I could hang down from my belt if there was a
fire,
right?
I could fucking hang down.
Okay.
And just fucking swing my legs jumped down to the next one and I could just go
all the way down the side of the thing.
You know,
that's where you're right there.
Can you do that through bench pressing and doing squats?
She can't fucking do that.
Okay.
You're old beast with muscles.
You're overdeveloping yourself.
All right.
Basically my message is if you're not doing what I'm doing,
you're an asshole.
Despite the fact I have no nutritional or training or any of that shit.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Hey,
let me hide some gigs here.
I'm next week,
I'm part of my seven week tour.
I am four weeks into this fucking thing,
by the way,
underrated for the week is the,
uh,
the comedy zone in Jacksonville,
Florida.
Any other comics are listening.
It's just a fucking old school comedy club.
It's in the Ramada.
It's got the brick wall behind you.
I absolutely fucking love the club that,
the setup.
It's just a semicircle.
Everybody's right there.
Fucking phenomenal crowds.
I didn't know what I was going to run into when I came out of it than I already
talk about this.
I started the podcast a couple of times.
Let me just get right to it.
I had a great time and I'm definitely gonna come back.
I'd like to come back,
um,
and go to that Georgia,
uh,
gator's game.
But I'm just worried that,
you know,
the games during the day,
everybody's going to be fucking hammered.
I'm going to get hammered.
Then I got to do shows.
No one's going to show up at some point.
I have to go to that God damn game.
But anyways,
I had a great time and I want to thank everybody who came up because,
uh,
I was finally able to work out that Hitler Stalin thing.
Bye Adnan Satchel Paige.
All right.
And if it wasn't such a great club,
I would have been closed off and I wanted to come up with it.
So,
um,
so there's that.
So next week the tour continues.
I'm going to be a go bananas in Montgomery,
Ohio,
just outside of Cincinnati,
October 5th and sixth,
and Paul,
dude,
I called it [inaudible] is going to be there and we're hanging around to go to
the fucking Bengals Dolphin's game on Sunday.
That'll be franchise.
Today's franchise number one 10.
That'll be franchise one 11,
one 11,
and I'll have 13 more to go.
Um,
after that,
I'll be fucking,
where the hell am I going to be?
I'm going to be in New York City on October 13th at the beacon theater on the
comedy central thing night.
At too many,
there's too many stars.
People.
Um,
well if you're booking me,
they should have been a night of not enough.
Don't enough stairs.
Um,
all right.
After that,
then I go to fucking Australia.
Okay.
I'm going to the Sydney Opera House.
October 18th,
19th and 20th,
another great sport.
Australian rules football.
Um,
Harris in New Orleans November 2nd.
I've never done stand up at any sort of a club in New Orleans.
I one time I did,
I did a club in,
uh,
I don't northern.
Okay.
Northern,
where the fuck was it?
Louisiana.
That's what I meant to say.
Not New Orleans.
I met and the Louisiana.
I'll be at Harris November 2nd and on November 3rd,
I'm going to Lsu,
Alabama.
Uh,
you liked this shit.
People,
he liked to shit.
Isn't this fucking,
isn't this a great life?
Traveling the road I'll be with first.
He again,
it's a phenomenal life.
You guys should all try.
You should all try being a fucking standup comedian at some point your life.
And then what you do is you continue to have failed pilots so you never get a
television show.
And as much as that hurts,
one day it hits you and you realize,
you know what?
It's kind of fucking awesome not to have a TV show
because I get to kind of just fucking go out here and make great money,
go to games,
do whatever the fuck I want to do,
say whatever I want to say.
And I don't have to deal with people going,
you know our advertisers are upset by that yet I'll go fuck yourself.
Go Fuck Yourself.
That's the thing.
You know when you get your own TV show you,
if they call it by your own name,
you know it's really not your TV show.
It's their TV show and they'll take it back whenever they fucking Goddamn want
to.
And then what do you do?
You go out and buy a big fucking,
I got my own TV show house and then all of a sudden you don't have a TV show,
but you still got the big,
I got my own TV show house and then what?
Now you got to go on the road.
Not because you want to,
cause you have to and you're going to go out there all fucking miserable and
everybody's yelling your catch phrase from the show,
right?
You fucking hate in life.
I avoided all of that through failed pilots.
I am.
I'm living the fucking dream.
I just had eggs benedict.
There were overcooked.
Did you do that?
I laid and he in a fucking hotel room,
picked up the phone and said,
listen bitch,
you bring me those fucking eggs.
You bring up to me now.
And then another woman knocked on my door,
said,
hey,
would you like some turndown service?
And I said,
no,
I would not,
but I would like some fresh towels immediately.
And she handed them to me and they were still warm.
Okay.
This is the word of the Lord.
Thanks be to God
all.
Alright,
anybody go to church today?
Oh,
I Lou [inaudible] Lou Ya.
You know I sat next to,
you know,
you guys think I'm tone deaf.
I sat next to one of the most tone deaf people.
You know,
it's underrated.
A fucking water taxi.
I'm looking at one right now.
I don't give a shit.
If you're going to the worst fucking job you've ever had in your life for that
moment,
when you're on that boat,
you're a free man.
It's like when they were drinking the beers on the roof and fucking Shawshank
redemption.
Um,
what was I going to say?
The fuck was that.
Oh,
I sat next to this lady,
this lady,
if you guys think that I'm a bad singer,
um,
which admittedly I am
the fucking,
uh,
the lady I was sitting next to,
she sat next to me and she goes,
uh,
told me she just came from a George Thorogood concert.
She goes,
yeah,
he just turned 63,
which really made me feel old.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
how was he?
So he goes,
oh,
he was great.
And then she goes,
she goes,
one whiskey,
wine,
Scotch,
and one beer.
First of all,
she didn't even get the words right.
It's one bourbon,
one scotch,
one beer,
and it's,
I don't even,
she wasn't even tone deaf.
She just,
for some reason couldn't remember the melody.
How do you not know that that's like one of his biggest fucking hits off that
cover song,
right?
Juan Bourbon Watch guards.
[inaudible] Albert Abdul Pardot,
right?
One.
Once you go one whiskey wine,
Scotch,
one be here.
I think she clapped as she was doing it to one whiskey.
One's got you one beer.
Anyway,
if like if I could have just fucking skydived onto the plane at that point I
would have,
it was so fucking horrific.
Um,
and she had a dog.
She had a dog with their little dock sound.
She had fucking drugged it up.
Jesus Christ.
This dog was freaking out.
It had this fucking fear and look in its eye all I got a bad feeling,
man.
I was so glad she told me that she drugged it up,
but I,
because if she didn't tell me,
she dragged it up and I saw that look in that poor dog's eyes,
I would have thought that it knew the plane was going to crash.
You know,
they always say that like dogs and dogs can,
they can sense of fucking earthquake.
It's so fucking dumb.
Can they really sense an earthquake or do they just hear it before we do because
they have better hearing the of that,
these dumb youtube videos of the dog sensing it and it like senses it like
fucking six seconds before people do.
That's not sensing it.
That's just your fucking laying on the floor and you're not wearing any clothes.
So you felt the vibrations before?
I did because I'm sitting in a chair wearing shoes.
You know,
if it
really fucking good sense it common,
it would have fucking,
you just see it one day just packing a suitcase and putting on,
it's fucking bing Crosby fedora.
And you'd be like,
Hey,
lucky.
Where are you going?
And just be like,
Listen Matt,
you know,
I know I've just a dog.
I don't wear clothes.
I can't drive a fucking car.
But I'm telling you it would be in your best interest to follow me right now
into the wilderness.
They never do that.
They just go off like fucking five seconds before you do and then they just
start running.
They don't stand in a doorway.
You know what it is?
Dogs get fucking hyped up because people have been hurt by other people.
Yeah.
You know,
and at some point they just,
you know,
they want dog,
like they like dog.
People wish that people would act like dogs.
Just always be excited,
always be happy.
Never call them on their shit.
You know,
just always freak out when I fucking come home.
Always do that.
Always be in a good mood.
And I gotta admit I'm one of those dog people.
I actually do this thing with Nia,
right?
I come home from the airport and I called her and I,
and I,
I make sure that she has the dog like in another room so it can hear me coming
up the walk.
Right.
It always ends up right as I get to the walk,
you know,
to head up to the house that doesn't have air conditioning.
[inaudible] skin standalone unit.
Um,
okay.
And then she just goes,
the second the dog stops cause it,
here's me,
close the door to the car.
She always goes,
she just looks at dawn goes,
who's that?
Who's that?
Cleo is that Daddy.
And then she fucking freaks.
And I hear a nails.
Is she trying to run across the hardwood floors?
Fucking slip.
Slide.
She fucking comes.
Just a ball of fucking muscle.
Come fly as to greatest.
It's the greatest fucking,
it's almost why I do the road.
Just to watch her freak the fuck up.
You're no.
Yeah.
I feel like the teen idols sensation when I come home.
Ah,
Jesus.
People.
Okay.
Where Joe to Rosa this weekend?
Where is that?
Kooky Egyptian.
All right,
let's go here.
All right.
College broads college broads a bill.
I'm a freshman in college right now and I've never seen so many good looking
ladies in one place,
in my entire life off.
And they're all single.
None of them are married.
They don't have any kids.
Bang them before they get fucking crazy.
Um,
what do we got here?
He says,
the problem is that I have trouble flirting with the ladies because I always get
anxious around them.
How can I start talking them?
Because I don't think I'll ever have an opportunity to meet hot girls like this
again in my life off.
Dude,
do you realize what a what a what a fucking in the moment.
Smart analysis that is.
You're absolutely right.
You're at like,
if you're at the club 24 fucking seven,
you live in with them.
All right?
This is like the NFL combine of Pussy.
So start fucking,
you know,
get out your clipboard and pick a winner.
All right,
don't go Ryan Leaf.
Go drew Bledsoe.
Um,
I don't know Rick Meyer,
that's who Seattle picked.
Um,
the pro.
What am I,
how can I still how girls,
but both the Duh,
Duh.
Um,
and have you been around so many hot girls like this again in my life,
so I don't make one.
I'll make the most out of these next four years for,
for,
uh,
what is the best way to start meeting these college hotties while I still have
the chance?
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Don't,
there's only one way to learn how to talk to ladies.
The ladies,
you just got to start doing it.
Okay.
And give yourself permission to suck at it,
you know,
to,
uh,
suck at it to suck at it.
It's just like,
it's just like doing comedy.
It's like learning how to swim.
They just throw in the deep end.
You start kicking.
That's all you do.
Don't kick the women.
That's not what I'm saying.
It was a bad fucking metaphor there.
Or similarly,
similarly,
like Arrez no,
it was a metaphor.
No I didn't.
I didn't say hitting on women is swimming.
I said it's like swimming.
Oh,
shut the fuck up bill.
Um,
yeah,
just start hitting on him.
You know what?
Just,
what is it?
How do you,
how do you,
how do you fucking drop in?
You know what it is?
You're going to figure out what works for you.
You're got to fit.
You're going to figure out,
hey,
do you have a sense of humor?
You know what I mean?
That's always great if you can make them laugh.
If you know,
I dunno,
we just,
I,
there's,
there's no way.
There's no way.
You just have to fucking go do it.
All right?
And if you stand there on the wall,
go,
Gee,
GOP,
you know what?
Some dose who's probably not,
you know,
isn't going to bring as much to the table as you are.
Right.
He,
the,
it's those assholes who just walk up to them and they just,
hey,
what do you say to a perfect text?
Uh,
just fucking with you.
Don't be like that.
Let me get you a drink.
And they put them in a headlock and they drag them up to the bar.
Those guys end up fucking them.
I mean,
that's an oversimplification.
And then people like
if you,
he may give it a review.
They do.
You've really biggest pages the world
right
now.
What happens?
He goes out and does what you're going to go home and jerk off to.
So what do you want to do,
sir?
Do you want to live in a fantasy world or do you want to live in reality?
Just go up and talk to them.
Yeah,
just do it.
I don't know.
Do something,
just be fucking,
you know,
obnoxious.
Just any,
anything.
Just try different things.
Try going up there and saying something.
Ron Burgundy,
which say,
you know your own,
I'm kind of a big deal.
Anything,
anything to get them fucking laughing,
right?
Something.
But for the love of God,
get off the fucking wall.
Um,
sleepwalked banging a Billy boy.
I need some advice for something I can guarantee you haven't gotten an email
about before.
This one is personal.
It's not really,
what are you hoping?
Your fucking God damn thing.
Just get to it.
All right.
Over the last year,
I have discovered that I engage in sleepwalking behavior.
The most hilarious part of it.
I think fucking Mike Birbiglia wrote a whole one man show that's now a movie
about this.
So I really don't think you're breaking new ground,
although I'll give you the,
I'll give you the benefit of the doubt.
The most hilarious part of it is that I engage in sleep,
sex.
Okay.
You know what?
Go Fuck Yourself.
Do you think I'm dumb enough to believe this?
You're either just making this shit up or you're a fucking pervert and you're
going around basically sexually assaulting other people.
And then,
ah,
I was asleep.
Sorry that I put my dick on your lip.
All at my fault.
I was sleeping.
Um,
anyways,
let,
let's,
let's just,
you know,
to fill up the hour.
I'm going to read the rest of this,
but I'm already calling bullshit cause I been with my girlfriend for four years
now and we're both 22 years old.
We share a room in a house together with other housemates and let me guess,
you wander in and accidentally fucked somebody else.
Is that what you're gonna tell me?
Is that really where this fucking email is going to go?
Um,
I've found out that if we don't have sex at least once every two days,
I will basically begin to perform sex acts on her while I sleep.
Dude,
you are so full of fucking shit.
Yeah,
I will have absolutely no memories of these.
Here's his out.
Oh,
did I fucking finger bang you with my Dick in your ass.
Sorry.
I was sleep.
Sleep's automizing.
Um,
I will have no memorize memories of these in the morning unless I wake up during
the act.
My girlfriend says that my eyes are open but totally glazed over when I do it.
The most common one is that I will go down on her.
This is so fucking stupid.
You're asleep.
Yeah.
You're asleep and you're dreaming,
right?
Your eyes are open,
but you're,
you're still like in rem sleep and you're somehow pulling the covers off.
Fine.
What are you a fucking Zombie?
I,
you know,
I'm not reading the rest of this.
This is the most ridiculous fucking die.
But you know what?
Maybe this people interested,
I'll keep reading.
This is the dumbest thing that sounds like a Scott movie from the
Ert list.
Was this the original draft of zapped?
Um,
somebody 43 years old,
just fucking did a spit take on the dashboard with that reference.
Um,
what the hell am I?
I have also fingered her as well.
Stupid.
The one that I am least proud of is that I apparently licked my own TJ's offer
boobs after all,
after coming
capital letters all in my sleep.
Dude,
this is the most bizarre fucking thing I've ever read.
My girlfriend is actually really cool about it.
Hey,
you asleep and it's fine,
honey.
Go like this.
No.
On the other side.
Yeah.
Yet.
You had a little more over there.
Uh,
at this.
At first she'll be really startled because she is sleeping too.
If I'm going down are in my sleep,
she generally,
let's keep going until she comes.
I'll usually wake up as she's coming,
we'll have sex and we'll both go back to sleep.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
I swear to God people.
There's two more paragraphs of this shit.
Do you want me to keep going?
The scary part to me is the fear of not having control over my body and my
actions.
I'm scared because I have clearly shown my ability to perform complete tasks
while being completely asleep and having absolutely no memory of them later.
I'm afraid that one day I'll find myself waking up,
driving my car down the highway.
I haven't shown myself doing anything dangerous yet.
You haven't shown my,
you haven't found yourself,
but who knows,
right.
The only reason I do know about the times it has happened so far is because my
girlfriend has been there to tell me it happened.
Who knows what crazy shit I've done before I met her in my sleep that I'll never
know about.
My girlfriend says,
I'm just being paranoid and then I should let it be.
Wait a minute,
you fucking came on your girlfriend's tits,
licked your own jazz off of him.
And she's like,
Oh,
you're just being paranoid.
Is this the white chick from every fucking horror movie?
Um,
I don't think that noise is anything to be concerned about.
um,
what would you do?
Would you go see a therapist or a doctor for this?
So would you just let it go?
I really don't.
Don't,
yeah,
this is beyond,
he goes,
I really don't want to be to go to a doctor with a bunch of pill.
You know what I would email Mike Birbiglia.
I actually think I vaguely remember him talking about walking over to a window
or something,
you know,
and doing something.
I can't remember.
You know,
I don't,
I don't remember.
I would email him or why don't,
yeah,
why don't you fuck,
but yeah,
go to another comedian now.
Fuck that.
Go.
Go talk to a professional.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
If that's,
if that's real.
Is it real son?
Is it really real son?
Um,
that's one of the big things in hip hop.
Everybody's got it.
Yo.
This is real.
This is like the cities where it's like,
dude,
it's all real me laying on a bed right now doing a podcast in Jacksonville
that's also real.
Everything's real son.
Um,
yeah.
If,
if it's actually going on.
Yeah,
man,
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't know what to tell you.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
my girlfriend is blackmailing me.
Jesus Christ.
Dear bill,
my ex girlfriend and I were together for two months before she wanted to watch
porn with me.
I was all hyped thinking that she was perfect and I,
and she said she picked the porno.
I didn't want to make a run comfortable.
The five ticked it.
Dude,
that's a good thing because if you're too far down the road,
you're going to fuck up the whole thing.
So that was actually a very smart move.
Kudos to you young man.
Um,
he goes tonight.
We did,
she turned on the video and it was a cartoon getting raped by a,
by a tentacle monster.
Okay.
And did an ORC or see,
I don't know what the fuck that is.
I'm not in this world.
Um,
I was disgusted and turned it off immediately and stop having sex with her.
I'll see.
You guys were having sex and then she turned on this fucking horrific cartoon.
Okay.
I've seen those.
I've never watched one.
When you go through,
I've seen like the cartoons.
When I go on the fuck,
I want to watch people banging.
I don't want to see like,
you know,
shaggy banging fucking,
what's her name?
Daphne.
Who was the hot one?
Um,
anyways,
I was disgusted and turned it off immediately.
Stop having sex with her.
She isn't some Geek.
She's super hot.
She started crying saying that I didn't have an open mind.
I left and broke up with her damn at school.
She spread it around that I was the one that shows the video.
Oh,
there's Versie a Versie.
I'm wrapping up my podcast.
Okay.
Farsi.
I'm wrapping up my podcast.
What's going on?
Not that I,
I'm,
I'm doing my podcast.
Jesus Christ.
Paul,
I'm wrapping it up.
I'm done one live right now talking to you.
Let me call you in like 12 minutes.
Hi.
Is there anything fucking people just can't get off the damn phone.
I gotta go.
Oh,
you got to go.
What are you going?
So anyways,
uh,
she has some Geek.
She's super hot.
She started crying.
Okay.
So I broke up with her after school.
She spread it around that I was the one that shows the video.
She then blackmailing me blackmailing me saying she'd stopped if we got back
together.
Ah,
for fuck sakes,
Joe to Rose's calling.
Ah,
Geez.
Joe,
I'm doing my podcast.
Yukon's let me call you back in 10 minutes.
Ah,
go fuck yourself Joe.
Tell it to somebody else.
Um,
or the hell am I.
Uh,
so she's,
she blackmailed me saying she'd stop if we get back together.
She'd stop what she already told everybody.
Okay.
My friends say I should,
I should get back together with her because she's hot.
That is the male brain at 20 years of age and that,
that I keeper getting teased.
I can't you,
you fucked up that sentence.
Do it.
I don't know if he deleted something.
He said,
even teachers look at me differently.
What should I do?
Minus throwing my 10 pound textbook at her head.
You know what?
Look Dude,
you know the real story and it's going to be in your face.
Okay.
When somebody comes up to you and was like,
Hey,
I heard you were watching that fucking a octopus raping that chick cartoon
video.
You just look.
Just be like,
oh yeah.
Is that what you heard?
Is that what she told you?
It'll,
why do you give a fuck?
I know you want to give a fuck cause it's your world,
dude.
The last thing you want to do is get together with her.
This is what you do.
Call her.
Hey,
this is what you do.
Oh,
I got it.
Here's what you do.
Why don't you just fucking record a phone conversation with her or have her come
over?
All right.
You fucking hit record on your fucking smartphone.
You have a come in and just say,
listen,
I'm sorry I broke up with you.
I'd really like to get back together with you,
but you have to promise me,
you will stop telling people that lie or whatever and you get it to admit it and
then you just talk to her for 10 minutes.
Why are you,
why do you think you're in to stuff like that?
And He'd get it to admit the whole fucking thing and then in the end just go,
you know what?
I just realized I don't want to get back together with,
and you kick her out cause fuck her and her feelings at this point.
All right.
And then you let us spread the fuck and rumor and then what you do is you just
upload onto your fucking page,
the audio.
Okay?
Yeah.
And then you become fucking,
oh no,
no,
don't do that.
Don't do that.
Cause then that,
that's all fucking mean.
This is what you do.
You fucking hit stop and just say,
listen,
I'm gonna tell you something off.
Then the next day when you guys were allegedly together,
you meet up with there in a coffee shop,
like fucking Mickey Rourke in the end to fucking
the pope of Greenwich Village.
And he say,
listen bitch,
we're not getting together and you're going to stop saying that shit about me.
You know why?
Cause I got a tape,
a tape,
I took off a dead cop and you fucking punch the side of her hand just like
you're talking to Burt young.
Okay.
Then you put fucking lie in a coffee,
Charlie.
No,
you don't do that.
That's what you do.
Just fucking recorder.
And this is the thing.
Don't put it on your Facebook page.
Just have it on your phone.
Okay.
And at any point,
anybody comes up to you and says it,
just say,
Oh yeah,
listen to this.
And then you play it for them and say,
there,
go fuck yourself.
And then that's it.
And eventually it'll get back to her that you have that fucking recording and
then she'll shut the fuck up.
But don't,
don't put it on your Facebook page because then somehow there'll be some sort of
cyber bullying and at the end of it she has a vagina and you have a dick.
So somehow you'll end up being wrong.
You know,
because if there's one thing I've learned,
the ladies are never wrong in the public eye because they can't bench press as
much as us.
That's basically what it comes down to.
All right,
here we go.
So that's what you do sir.
Just pretend like you getting back together with her and then go into an in
depth conversation about why she's into those videos and why she would go out
and hurt you like that when you would never do something like that to her.
Okay.
Don't say you're going to get back together.
Just say,
I want to talk about this,
I have to think about this.
And just delve into all of that and ask her why she would do something like
that.
And then in the end just be like,
you know,
I don't know.
I need to think about this.
And then you walk dramatically over to the window and she,
then she goes,
this is that me,
where's it back together?
And then you go out,
just get out and then,
then you got the tape and then you got an anybody gives you any shit.
And just say,
I got audio of her talking about why she's into it.
All right.
And then call her and then call her.
I'm telling,
just say,
listen,
I recorded that conversation last night.
So,
uh,
I,
it's in your best interest to shut the fuck up.
All right,
so why don't you go find a squid,
the shoving you're taught and leave me out of it.
And that's the news and nobody here.
I've bill,
should I fly the coop and leave my boring boyfriend?
Yes,
absolutely.
That's it.
I don't even need to read it.
You're thinking about leaving because your boyfriend boards the shit out of you.
You know,
if you want longevity,
you've got to have somebody that keeps your fucking heart going.
Pitter patter.
Derris billion.
How's it going?
I'm a 30 to 32 year old lady and need some advice.
I moved to a new place about a year ago to be with my boyfriend and everything
with him is perfect.
We laugh a lot.
The sex is great and rarely argue it's a dream.
My issue is where we live and who we live with.
Oh Shit.
This has nothing to do with them.
See this,
this is why you read them.
Um,
where the hell am I here?
Uh,
we laugh a lot.
Sex as bait beat,
but didn't do it.
My issue is,
is where we live and who we live with.
I hate the area that we live in and my guts thinks we live in a paradise or my
guy thinks we live in a paradise and doesn't want to move.
We also live with a mean ass relative of his that he is caring for.
Oh,
Jesus.
Oh Jesus.
Okay.
First of all,
I'm just going to say you're a saint for actually putting up with this,
this law not being married to somebody and you're fucking with their goddamn
enlarged some shit.
Um,
I help take care of this surly fuck too,
but I'm over it.
I'm thinking about bailing ship.
I feel bad about it because one,
who am I kidding?
I'm old and the baby machine is ready for distribution to the guy I'm with is
honestly the nicest person that I've ever met.
Anything you in the lovely Nia can suggest would be appreciated.
By the way.
Thanks for making the beginning of my week a little better.
Oh,
look at you.
You're a sweetheart.
All right.
See love this guy.
You just have to sit down with them and just be,
listen sweetheart,
we're better than this.
Okay.
You know,
I hate living here.
It's the very least.
I think you would be a lot happier if you could just not be living with the
surly motherfucker.
You know?
Is there any way you guys can live someplace nearby?
Can you have that surly fuck like in a shed,
you know,
like that sling,
the sling blades,
a brother that they buried in that hole in the backyard.
You know,
can you just,
can you,
can you go down to home depot and just buy some sort of fucking four walled
structure with a roof and just stick that fucker in there with a,
a,
you know,
with an air conditioned wall unit.
Can we get a wall unit at least?
Um,
yeah,
I don't think that,
you know,
if you really love this guy,
you shouldn't leave them over this.
But like if this guy loves you,
you can actually sit down and have a conversation and just be like,
listen,
I'm miserable.
You know,
if I was ever with Nia and she's just like,
listen,
I fucking hate La.
I can't deal with this anymore.
I gotta get Outta here.
You know,
now she said,
I want to go live in Kansas.
I'd be like,
well,
I don't think I could make a living out there and we need to talk,
but you know,
she wants to go back to New York.
I would go back,
you know,
so who knows,
just have the conversation.
Have you had a conversation with them,
have the conversation,
see how it goes
and then fucking write me back.
Let me know what's up.
All right.
That's it.
Underrated comedy zone in Jacksonville already said that youtube video of the
week.
All right,
I got this one for you.
This is a deep purple video.
New York,
1973 live concert.
They're fucking amazing.
But and also you gotta you gotta you gotta listen to this at five 46 in the
video.
This,
this fucking epic moment happens right here.
Let me make sure,
turn this up.
This happens,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Just for that.
I think he was out trying to,
he was trying to out Robert Plant.
Robert Plant.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you to everybody.
Came out to the shows.
I'm really looking forward to go to bed.
Go Bananas in Cincinnati my fucking hour.
I got it.
It's down mother fuckers.
I got the new hour.
You will show up.
Even if you've downloaded my special tomorrow,
watch that thing.
Wire to wire.
Memorize the whole thing.
You will not see one repeated joke.
Okay.
All brand new shit.
I'm bringing the fire shit is rare.
Um,
what else do we got here?
What do we all do?
We,
I got a couple more advertising things.
I want amazon.com.
Everybody.
Do you want to fucking support my podcast and support the troops?
Well by Golly,
I have a way to do it.
Go to my podcast page.
Click on the Amazon banner and what do you do?
You go to Amazon and go buy yourself a pair of fucking chopsticks.
Okay,
they kicked me a little bit of money and I take 10% of that and I give it to the
wounded warriors project cause he's supporting the pro,
this podcast and supporting the troops.
It's about as good as it can get.
It's a fucking two for one till killing two birds,
one stone.
Um,
and also gain fly.com.
Would you like to have 8,000 video games at your disposal for a free two week
trial?
Go to www.game fly.com/bill burr and God dammit,
get yourself some video games.
Go into another world and shoot a bunch of people and get rid of the stress,
underrated going to a gun range.
Learning how to load a gun.
Learning how to squeeze that trigger.
Man,
that's a podcast for this week.
Please download my special on please.
Please don't.
Please don't upload it onto youtube.
Please don't do that.
Just like I said,
I don't give a fuck in like six months.
If you want to put some clips up there at that point,
you know whoever's going to buy it is going to fucking buy it.
I don't give a ship.
Just just give me the chance to fucking make my money back.
All right.
Keep in mind that bill Ybor has to make his money back or his next show will be
a CD audio.
Fucking only go fuck yourselves for all ages.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.